each film i've tried to take something
i've one of the costumes which was
shipped from
the uk back when i did
thor 2 and i brought it up in a big
shipping container and i thought great
i'm going to put it in my you know in
the games room or somewhere you know
it's still at my parents place in the
garage in that box
[Music]
when i got the film it was a number of
things went through my head
firstly it was great to be employed it
was great i was going to extend my visa
i was going to be a part of something
which sounded big and exciting but i
didn't have a whole lot of detail beyond
that and it was
you know a leap of faith on one hand as
far as what was being pitched but pretty
easy leap in the sense that um i didn't
have any other options i don't think
you've been completely honest with me no
this son of cole you and i we fight for
the same cause the protection of this
world from this day forward you can
count me as your ally if you return the
items you have taken from jane stolen
borrowed each time you play character
it's about what you bring to it
obviously but
so much of it is about who you're
interacting with and that can be other
actors the writers the producers
director the crew you know everybody has
some sort of influence in some way
that's what's been such a joy about
playing the character over the course of
10 11 years
is working with different directors and
seeing what different directors expect
want to pull out of the character you
know we had built this incredible
world with kenneth branagh and
i think we really nailed the sort of
vulnerability and the fish out of water
and this this individual
coming to terms with who he was and what
his place in the world was and and then
with taika waititi it was about doing
something different and unexpected and
so we
really dismantled the world we
dismantled the character we put him in a
very different place and environment
than he'd been in the past
uh we changed his look a dramatic
haircut which was you know um a risk to
the the comic book fans for a minute
there
[Music]
please kinda do not cut my hair it was a
constant exploration of what else we
could do and staying away from what felt
familiar that was our duty at that point
to service the character in the world in
a different unique fresh way for the
audience
yes
hey hey
we know each other he's a friend from
work
i had
the the tricky task of having this
otherworldly
god-like figure
that i was playing but trying to make it
relatable
and i think when the character didn't
work at times was because
we didn't have relatable features within
his his personality and his experiences
that anyone could really sort of
gravitate toward or empathize with or
understand or connect with end game in
particular yeah there was the dealing
with sort of the mental health of the
character um
and he's sort of
the altering of moods and depression if
you if you will i know you think i'm
down there wallowing in my own self-pity
waiting to be rescued and and saved but
i'm fine okay we're fine aren't we oh
good here mate so whatever it is that
you're offering we're not into it don't
care couldn't care less
goodbye
[Music]
and due to tragedy loss suffering
which you know all of us as human beings
have experienced in some way shape or
form
and those elements i do believe allowed
us to have some great connective tissue
between an audience and and
and this larger-than-life character and
each time since then i've
we've really had to dissect that and say
well what mental state is he now where's
his mental fitness or his mental
toughness is he um healthy enough to
deal with this if not how does he deal
with it
[Music]
what am i looking at oh sometimes it
takes a second
the original hammer actually a friend of
mine called me and said
is this yours and we'd used it in a
documentary that i was shooting that she
was a part of and it ended up at her
place and she said do you want it back
and i said yeah i think i think i should
get that one back
the opportunity to work with ron howard
um was the initial attraction i didn't
know anything about the story of nikki
louder and james hunt my dad used to
race motorbikes
so i was understood the sort of
that world a little this was obviously
formula one in cars but there's such a
you know it's it's it's a very similar
sort of space to
[Music]
make up for that inhabit
[Applause]
the leaders have spun out so it wasn't
unfamiliar but i had a lot of work to do
as far as understanding who this
character was and what the mindset of a
formula one driver was at the time and
especially in the 70s you know they were
the statistics
were incredibly intimidating as far as
would you survive the season or not
incredibly dangerous sport to partake in
we looked a lot at
what the discipline and mindset of those
individuals were and nikki louder
embodied the absolute precision and the
prep and the quiet discipline and focus
whereas james hunt went i'm going to
launch myself into the adrenaline side
of things and have it be as as
visceral and animalistic as possible and
he had huge talent obviously as a race
car driver um but a very different
mentality to nikki lauda that move was
called the suicide what if i hadn't
break we'd have crashed
we didn't did we
thanks to your impeccable survival
instincts
[ __ ] you
what's your name
james simon wallace hunt
remember it my little jelly friend of
all her members the physicality of the
character was completely different to
what i'd been doing um i had to like
lose a lot of weight off the back of
huntsman and thor and get and fit into
the race car and then
comes the challenge of playing a real
life individual and someone that people
adored and look up to and and it
inspired many many people in a
generation of drivers and so on and had
fans across the world that was
a pretty nerve-wracking task i just kind
of
allowed that fear
um
to to motivate me into my prep and it's
andretti who has the lead but hunt is
attacking
the outside of andretti
we had a number of days where we were in
the cars ourselves um there were
replicas of those cars and it was
exhilarating and exciting and uh
some of the
most enjoyable prep i've had to do we
then had
you know these cars that were driving
set up with
cameras all over them sort of smaller
cameras mounted on our helmet
super close up you know i'm focused on
one eyeball at times on each wheel
behind us in front of us and so on and
so as we drive around the track and
weave through with the other drivers
we were getting real in camera action
that uh you know you couldn't really
produce on a
vfx stage as much i think without that
authenticity and then we had a stunt
drive stunt crew and stunt drivers come
in and do the extreme stuff and they
were kind of bumper-to-bumper and
weaving in and out as they would in a
real race the blending of us being
inserted into that environment and and
and those guys as well gave such
impressive
footage and as you say experience for
the audience member it was a really
exciting thing to
to be a part of
i had just done saturday night live i
think
and i did a cameo and a film vacation
and so i'd done a little bit of comedy
which paul feig had seen and thought oh
he should play this character and the
script was great and fun i loved all the
the women who were going to work in the
film we're going to play those parts but
i said to paul there's not a whole lot
on the page like what what do you want
me doing he said oh we'll figure out
when you get here so i said okay why not
let's go and i got there uh turned up to
the studio the day before we started
shooting and
he handed me the script i read the
script and i said there's still nothing
in here like what am i what am i doing
and he said it's okay we're going to
improvise and have fun and
my immediate reaction was i
this is not on the end of my career but
i'm going to ruin this film i'm going to
let everyone down i haven't done this
before what am i doing and then i met
melissa mccarthy christian wig the whole
crew the cast and i just became a whole
lot more comfortable because there was
such a sense of camaraderie and and and
collaboration there at play um and they
took me under their wing and we just
went on this adventure this wacky
adventure of discovering who this
character was what have you been doing
with your whole life great question oh
well um lots of different jobs um i did
the um did the actor thing uh worked for
tonight just real quick um can i ask why
no no glass oh oh yeah they just kept
getting dirty so i took them out
i don't have to clean them anymore no
boy
i gotta i gotta try to keep that in mind
90 of it was improvised and in the
moment and um
not often do you have an environment to
really do that in you know people talk
about
improvisation
but usually it's they've got a couple of
things tucked away in their pockets and
they're going to say that on camera
which is not quite improvisation whereas
this was you know melissa would say i
want to try something and just start
coming at me with a line and then i'd
have to sort of sink or swim and try to
come up with something to throw back and
so on and incredibly freeing because
there was still a lot of
you know the sort of
anxiety bubbling under the surface but
it just became so much fun it just
became
about trying to not laugh about trying
to make the other person laugh it
reminded me of a drama class or being
back in high school or something and
thought i want to take that into
everything i do you know i want to be
able to have that much fun i want it to
be
a wonderful collaboration and
exploration as that was
the character was a pretty broken
individual one who deep down had a lot
of courage in there somewhere but it was
buried through very depressive
experience the loss of his his wife and
family and so he was you know searching
for answers at the bottom of a
bottle but that
kind of attitude this sort of rashness
the
it was a carefree um
chaotic sort of nature to him which
allowed us to have a lot of fun with it
i seem to drunk at all but you're
welcome to it when it comes out again
again i was still happy to be employed
and to be working in big big films and
big entertainment popcorn blockbusters
if you will that was the films i loved
growing up but i also had an appetite to
do
um some more smaller character-based
kind of films where special effects and
big action scenes weren't necessarily
the most dominant force much has been
made
about the punch that you caught from
kristen stewart oh yeah
have you forgiven her for that
oh yeah no i i was more upset that she
didn't continue on through the take she
kind of hit me and then immediately went
oh my god i'm so sorry i was like that
would have been that would be the
perfect
uh most truthful take we had i think she
was more upset than i was
[Music]
it was unlike anything
i'd read before um the world that was
created was unique and fresh
the character
itself was vastly different to anything
i'd done before i was intrigued by the
questions it was posing and um
you know this search for understanding
of human emotion and can we manipulate
that and can we have mood-altering
substances and and drugs and and so on
from a pharmaceutical group jeff heather
can i have your permission to administer
n40 drip on
acknowledge
oh yeah
acknowledge thank you for me i just saw
an opportunity
to
explore a space and try things i hadn't
done before just about every actor
loves that process and you know where it
is just about performance you're working
with different individuals and if you
have an idea of how you think they're
going to play it
and they do something different and
immediately you've got to pivot and
adjust and so on i like the spontaneity
to that i like
being forced
into a place of unknown and then you are
truly in the moment
come on guys words words words okay yeah
she's starting to look pretty good
there was a great script there joe
kaczynski was already directing
and it was right in the middle of covert
and lockdowns and restrictions and
everything we also wanted a film that we
could shoot on a sound stage with three
or four or five actors in a confined
space controlled environment and this
red like a play it i think it could be a
stage play the way it presents itself
and unfolds so we were all really
excited about the practicality of being
able to
shoot during that time
yeah i could
i could
good what jeff
[Music]
i think it was going to shoot
maybe in in
in the us at one point i was in
australia um so as far as a producing
element of it i said look there's some
great spaces in australia to shoot you
know incredible crews and casts that we
could utilise and to their credit and
netflix
and the product whole production team to
be able to pivot from wherever they were
shooting before and put it in australia
and set it up i think within you know
felt like six or eight weeks
and then to shoot it in about six weeks
i think was pretty remarkable